Joe: A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's McDonald's.
This is "Food Wars."
We'll start with some things
you can find in the UK
but I think might be
slightly different over here.
Let's start with the
iconic McDonald's Big Mac.
So, I mean, visually,
looks pretty much the same.
You've got the quite
sad, flimsy beef patties.
Let's give it a try.
So, I think there are some
subtle differences there,
actually. Like, broadly speaking,
if you gave it to me and were
like, "This is a UK Big Mac,"
I don't think I would doubt you.
I think it's the sauce,
because the UK Big Mac sauce
has got quite a tang to it,
almost, and this is very gentle.
I barely get anything from it.
The Big Mac. Now, this
looks exactly like a Big Mac
anywhere in the world.
You know what I gotta do. Oop and oop.
Now let's give this a shot.
If that isn't exactly
the same, it's close.
I mean, if I could do one side
by side I'd probably notice,
but I do not taste any difference.
I remember when we did
"Fast-Food Chemistry,"
you guys had more
chemicals and stuff to use,
but I'm here to say
the chemicals have not
made a striking difference.
It tastes almost exactly the same.
Then we're on to the fries and
the Coke aspect of the meal.
Firstly, I have to point
out how enormous these are.
The size of this drink is ridiculous.
This is way bigger
than almost any fast-food
drink I've seen in the UK ever.
Even the fries as well.
This box of fries is huge.
They've kind of sunk down a little bit,
so it doesn't really show how full it was.
But this carton is massive.
You can fit so many fries in here.
It feels like almost double the size
of a carton of UK fries.
I mean, these are pretty good.
I will say, I think they've
held up a lot better
after a bit of time out of the fryer
than UK fries have.
UK McDonald's fries, I think maybe
because they don't have
as many ingredients,
there aren't the preservative
chemicals in there,
they don't really hold
up very well at all.
As soon as they come out the fryer,
they kind of just get
worse and worse and worse.
So you have to eat them
really while they're hot.
I think taste-wise,
there are some slight differences as well.
There is something more than
just salt going on here.
So, I only know this because we made
that "Fast-Food Chemistry"
episode of McDonald's fries,
but there is a sort of
artificial-beef flavor
that's added to these, and
you do kind of taste it.
It's very subtle, but there's a kind of
savory depth of flavor to these
that you just don't get in the UK.
I kind of like it. I can't lie.
My first thing about these fries,
these guys are pale looking.
Not the bright yellow I'm
used to in the States.
The whole thing is just potato,
salt, and oil, that's it?
Yeah, and I believe it,
because these are bland.
Man!
What?
Mm-mm, no on the fries.
USA ones are way better.
And then finally, this
enormous McDonald's Coke.
I don't know what it is
about McDonald's Coke,
but it just always hits different.
That happens in the UK
and, yeah, kind of still happens here.
Another iconic menu item
that I thought was worth
trying was McNuggets.
So, just visually speaking,
before I even try it,
these look quite different
to British McNuggets.
I'm fairly sure the ones
in the UK are deep-fried.
Correct me if I'm wrong, editor.
But these ones look almost
more deep-fried somehow,
just in terms of the way that the breading
has kind of puffed up and
blistered a little bit.
I will say, I think the breading
maybe has slightly more seasoning,
a bit more flavor going
on here than I'm used to.
The chicken itself I think
is pretty much the same.
I think I might prefer
British nuggets. Sorry, guys.
Nuggets look like almost
exactly the same size,
smell the same, same amount
of crispness on the skin.
No, much blander. Much blander.
You guys are getting a terrible deal
with these nuggets, because this is dry.
I did notice it says
"100% chicken breast meat"
on this one.
I do not know if that's
the case in America.
Can we get that on-screen?
But I've just been informed, no,
of the chicken that they use,
100% of it is chicken breast meat,
but it's only 45% chicken, right?
It says "100% chicken breast" on it.
The implication there is that
the chicken is 100% chicken,
or it's 100% chicken meat.
It is not. Deceptive!
The last thing we wanted to compare
in both countries was the McCrispy.
Here is an American McCrispy.
It looks fairly similar
to ours on the surface.
This one I think is a
potato roll rather than
the more pretzel-y brioche version
that you find in the UK.
There's no sauce.
It's just pickles and
a fried chicken patty.
I really like the pickles.
I think pickles and fried
chicken is a great combination,
and it's not super common in the UK.
I will say, I think it needs a sauce.
I think technically they claim
that they butter the rolls
and that butter is I
guess therefore the sauce,
but it's kind of dry.
The chicken's just a
little bit thin as well.
I feel like the McCrispy
in the UK tends to be
a thicker and slightly
juicier piece of chicken.
This is a fairly thin and
quite dry chicken breast.
The McCrispy.
Harry: Yellow box.
Oh, nice! All right.
I'm pleasantly surprised by the bun.
It reminds me of King's Hawaiian rolls.
Yeah, this looks like our McChicken.
It is so close to the McChicken.
Better bun than the McChicken,
but the crispiness of the chicken patty.
It tastes slightly different.
I would say the McChicken sauce is,
I hate to say it, is a bit sweeter.
Because I love the McChicken.
Like, the taste of that is in my DNA.
Here are all the US menu items
you won't find at a UK McDonald's.
Here's all the UK McDonald's menu items
I can't get in the US.
We'll start with some chicken options,
namely the deluxe McCrispy
and the spicy deluxe McCrispy.
Let's take a look at the deluxe McCrispy
and see what exactly they're
adding to make it deluxe.
The roll looks pretty much the
same as the standard version.
The chicken looks the same.
But I think when they say deluxe,
that just means they've added
mayo, lettuce, and tomato.
I don't know if that is enough
to qualify something as deluxe.
Doesn't seem super deluxe to me.
I also think that tomato is
just a bad topping for a burger.
They've kind of made this
worse, in my opinion.
I'm going to take a bite
of the spicy one and see
if it's good and if it's spicy.
It does have some heat to
it. They weren't kidding.
For my measly British-person palate.
I think I would probably
just buy the regular version
of the McCrispy and then
add some sauce to it.
So, you got a bacon mayo
chicken and a mayo chicken.
No, this might be exactly
what the McChicken's like.
Nah, it's a little wimpier.
Yeah. Is this what you're talking about?
Like, it's a big McNugget? Yeah.
The mayo's weird. Has a
really stale aftertaste.
I'm telling you, your guys'
breaded chicken at McDonald's
has no flavor compared
to the one in the US.
The McCrispy was crispier,
had more flavor in the sauce,
and the bun was nicer.
Yeah, this is a bummer.
Ugh, we got the same with
bacon. Do I really have to ...
No.
Look at how flimsy your bacon is.
Now we're on to some beef options,
starting with the McDouble.
I have just some kind
of existential questions
about the McDouble.
Namely, why does it exist?
Because we have the double cheeseburger.
Let's give it try.
I'm genuinely curious,
like, how is this different
to just a double cheeseburger, Joe?
One slice of cheese. Joe
says one slice of cheese.
Talk me through it.
OK, so what's going on
here is that the McDouble
has one slice of cheese in between,
where with double cheese, we
have two slices of cheese.
I think that's the only difference.
I honestly think it's, right,
because this is just, like,
the standard McDonald's.
Yeah, this looks very normal.
Right? It's just one less slice of cheese
from what we can tell. And
the price difference is,
let's get that on-screen.
So if you want to save
that amount of money,
get yourself a McDouble
and pass the savings on to you.
There you go. Cheers, Joe.
You heard it here first.
Next up we have the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
So, similarly to the McCrispy,
they've turned this thing
into a deluxe burger
by just adding some lettuce,
some mayo, and some tomato.
You know what they've tried to do here?
They've tried to just make a Whopper.
This is the double Quarter
Pounder with bacon.
Now this is a burger.
This one does what you would
expect a Quarter Pounder to do.
It's just loads of meat and cheese.
I want to talk more
about this bacon as well,
because this bacon's good.
One thing that I think we
do quite badly in the UK
at fast food is bacon.
A lot of the bacon you'll
find on UK restaurants
is this very pallid pink color,
whereas this one, stronger flavor,
you get some smokiness from it.
The bacon on this is way better,
and therefore that makes
it a very enjoyable burger.
Yes, I think the deluxe
should just be more beef
and some bacon rather than vegetables
that no one wants to eat. Come on.
Oh, yeah, now we're talking. Two patties.
Although, I'm telling you
guys, the patty on patty
with nothing in the middle is just weird.
A poppy-sesame-seed-bun hybrid?
Whoa!
Yeah, it doesn't look like barbecue sauce.
Barbecue sauce is, like, an amber brown.
Eh.
I think the bacon kind of screws it up
because your bacon is so flimsy.
I think this would work
with American bacon,
because American bacon would
just be, like, crisp —
I mean, it's not like
it has to be crispier.
It's just, this is really rubbery.
What do you guys think barbecue sauce is?
Bacon double cheeseburger.
I'm not impressed with
your bacon here, guys.
I'm not impressed.
Look. Look at ...
everyone in America,
look how weird this is.
Yeah, like ...
I'm pretty sure we had a
bacon double cheeseburger
at some point at McDonald's,
and it wasn't like this.
Our bacon is crispier, more
dispersed evenly, I guess.
Just have two strips going
right through the middle here.
That's a disaster. It's a total disaster!
All right, McPlant. Harry, get in here
and explain to me what
I'm doing, what this is.
This is the McPlant. It's
McDonald's fake-meat burger.
It took them ages to develop this.
They tested it in Scandinavia first.
It was available in Sweden for a while.
They also developed their own vegan cheese
because McDonald's couldn't
find a commercial vegan cheese
that they thought was good enough.
Yeah, I believe it. Look at
this. This looks terrifying.
I'll leave you to it, buddy.
Thanks, bud. What he said.
I think it was only available
in a few places in the US.
Came and went.
So, at least the US audience,
not impressed with the McPlant.
Yeah, that's not good.
There is definitely some
plant-based meat that tastes good,
that tastes like meat.
This ain't it.
I want to take this moment
to try your UK Coca-Cola.
Man, the Coke here is way better.
You guys make it with real sugar.
F--- off with this!
Does this ... ?
And these are the dippers, right?
Who do you think you are, McDonald's?
Who do you think you are, doing this?
You just took the dippers and put them ...
Oh, God, gross!
What is this, like ... what is this?
Vegetables.
Yo, this sucks ass, dude.
Yeah, the vegetarian says he loves them.
Put a asterisk next to that.
Of all the things he
can eat at McDonald's,
there's two, right?
And this is one of them. So OK, great.
I never want this.
Moving on.
Ah, Chicken Selects.
This is closer to what our McChicken
and our nuggets taste like.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, wish we had this in America.
The sour cream and chive
dip is really good.
Here are all the
exclusive wraps and salads
that you can find in the US
that you won't find in the UK.
That's not a mistake. There
are just none of them.
It's not even that there's no exclusives.
There's just no wraps
or salads, full stop,
on a US McDonald's menu.
Joe: USA!
I can't exactly say that
the UK salads are good
at McDonald's, but at least
we have them, you know?
You have an option if you
somehow are trying to eat healthy
but have ended up in a McDonald's anyway.
Whereas in America the closest
thing you have to a salad
is this bag of apple slices.
Oh, my God. I hate wraps.
This is a really smart way
of presenting this. A pita.
Isn't that a pita?
Harry: Tortilla, isn't it?
Oh, yeah. I guess it's
closer to a tortilla.
Leon: Also, the way you say it.
Joe: "Peed-a."
Leon: Yeah.
How do you say it?
Leon: "Pit-ta."
No, that's wrong. It's
with an I. "Peed-a."
Charlie: I would say "pit-ta."
Well, you'd be wrong.
Ugh, what kind of dressing is this?
Well, it says garlic, but
it's not very garlicky.
OK, so then we have the
grilled version of this. Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
What flavor could this possibly have?
Oh, come on.
Charlie: I thought that
was a bit of bread!
No.
Oh, man. That has no flavor.
Yeah, you can get a grilled-
or crispy-chicken salad,
but we didn't get them
because I didn't fly across
the planet to eat a salad.
Hey, this is fun. Nacho cheese wedges.
Well, we're much further from Mexico,
so how good could the
nacho cheese actually be?
Not bad.
It's certainly the most
flavorful thing I've eaten today.
Now it's time for the
exclusive condiments,
and you know what that means.
S-s-s-s-s-s-sauce talk.
The very first sauce
talk, "Foreign Exchange."
Sauce talk.
We're going to start with
this one, spicy Buffalo.
Yeah, so I think that's
the same one that they put
on the spicy McCrispy.
It's pretty good. It's basically
like if you take a mayo
and just pour some Frank's RedHot in it.
Let's try the honey mustard out.
I personally love a honey mustard.
You certainly get the
honey. It's pretty good.
I think the balance of that
is more on the honey side,
and it needs to swing slightly
more to the mustard side.
Now, this one I'm excited for.
It's ranch. We call it
"rahnch," not ranch.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Yeah, it's got a sort of herby tang to it.
Then we've got a couple of condiments
which are technically breakfast items
but we're going to count
under sauce talk anyway.
We'll start with the mild picante salsa.
I think this is supposed to be paired
with the breakfast burrito,
which we will get onto later.
But I'm going to try it with a nugget.
Joe: Oh, Jesus.
OK, that's enough.
Just do it.
Does what it says on the tin.
That's just a mild salsa, really.
Also on the breakfast-condiments list,
we have hotcake syrup.
I guess, like, maybe
legally they're not allowed
to call it maple syrup, so hotcake syrup.
I mean, people eat pancakes
with bacon and maple syrup,
so why can't chicken nuggets
and maple syrup go together?
OK, I thought I'd invented
something special there,
but nope, turns out I cannot claim
that combination as my own.
It's butter.
They have butter on the menu.
I think, again, designed to
be used with the hotcakes.
The final condiment
option is some grape jam.
I will say, we don't tend to have many
grape-flavored products in
the UK for whatever reason.
Mm.
Joe: Yeah?
It's pretty tasty.
Maybe not in combination with the chicken,
but the grape jam is quite nice.
Already, your ketchup, it's bizarre.
It makes sense why this would be ketchup,
considering what ketchup is.
But American ketchup is way sweeter.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing,
but I'm eating that, and I'm like,
if that was on a plate,
I was eating somewhere
that that was on a plate
and I was dipping into it,
I'd be like, "Oh, what sauce is this?"
Because I wouldn't think that's ketchup.
Like, "Oh, it's this fun
tomato sauce you got."
I wouldn't go, "Oh, ketchup."
Yeah, it's that different.
OK, the barbecue sauce, from
the country with no barbecue.
Let's see what you guys
think barbecue is. Nope.
I don't know what this is supposed to be.
Sweet chili dip. Here we go.
Better. Just OK.
McDonald's barbecue sauce is its own
special brand of barbecue sauce.
Yeah, this is pretty close to it, but
this one's a little more mustardy.
So, OK. Yeah, it's not bad.
All right, sweet and sour.
Ooh, that's really good.
Oh, hell yeah, dude. Sweet
curry. Been waiting for this.
That's really good!
We don't have any exclusive options
when it comes to the
food inside a Happy Meal,
but I did want to get one and just kind of
see what the vibe was, see
what the toy is, crucially.
So, at the time of recording this,
"The Little Mermaid"
hit theaters recently,
so they seem to be doing a
collab with "The Little Mermaid."
Does that mean I'm going to
get a "Little Mermaid" toy?
Let's find out.
So, we get — oh, these fries are so cute.
So, this is a UK large. [Joe laughing]
This is what I'm used to.
I will say, in the UK, the
fries come in a paper bag
rather than one of these
simply adorable little cartons,
which, honestly, huge fan of.
I went for the McNuggets,
which tend to come in a box of four.
Ah, there you go. You get
the apple slices within that.
This is the American salad.
And, of course, we get a toy.
Oh, it's King Triton! Let's go!
"Place your toy on a phone
or tablet for more fun,"
which I do think we have
to try and do real quick.
OK, try again. OK, put it down.
Put my phone on the desk.
You guys are getting this, right?
Getting all of this? This is crucial.
Place your toy on there. Pick a thing.
I'll just go there.
OK. Play the game.
"Turn your sound on."
[water swooshing]
I'm going to be honest. This is a miss.
Some kind of pattern? "Learn pattern."
That one, that one.
[water swooshing]
Did it. I win.
DC Happy Meal.
I've been told that it's —
one second. We got the toy.
Oh, Poison Ivy. Fast-food
fish is way more popular here.
You guys love your fast fish. I do not.
It smells fishy.
For the first time,
your food being flavorless
is a good thing.
Fries. Yeah, actually,
I would say this is also our kids size.
Let's take a look at the Poison Ivy toy.
What the hell? What is — OK.
Oh, there's something inside.
Ah, stickers, a game.
All right. Fun for kids.
Now we're on to some
McCafé and dessert options.
Unfortunately, I couldn't
get a few of these,
but here are the ones that
I was able to find today.
We'll start with a good
old-fashioned American
chocolate chip cookie.
This looks pretty good.
We're kind of bad at cookies in the UK.
I don't know what it
is, but they tend to be
very dry and crumbly
rather than soft and chewy.
That's not bad.
What's more American than apple pie?
I'll tell you what, an
apple pie from McDonald's.
This is the American McDonald's apple pie.
In the UK, a McDonald's apple
pie is actually deep-fried.
It just looks very different.
This is a baked apple pie,
so you get more of a lattice going on.
You see the filling there, but it's baked,
so I guess they don't need
to seal it on every side
because it's not going in a fryer.
It's not all going to
spill out into the oil.
I don't know if it's
going to hold up or not.
I think the UK might be
doing better apple pies
than the US is, at least
when it comes to McDonald's.
The pastry's fine.
The filling tastes pretty much identical
to the filling of a UK apple pie.
But yeah, like, the baked pastry
is just not the same as fried pastry.
And then there's actually
another pie option
on the menu right now at a US McDonald's.
This one is a strawberry cream pie.
That's pretty good.
As I said, there were
some desserts and pastries
that we weren't able to
get today. Here they are.
In the UK, you can also
get exclusive McFlurries.
Could not get them because,
you're not going to believe it,
but the ice cream machines
are also broken in the UK.
You can get yourself a Maltesers McFlurry
and a Smarties McFlurry.
OK, we got the McCafé snacks.
First up, oh, a doughnut.
Hey, who doesn't like a doughnut?
Ooh, yo!
This one is covered in
sugar. Look at that.
Muffin. Berry. Berry muffin.
A millionaire's doughnut, huh?
Ooh, with the cream inside?
It is pretty decadent.
I don't know if I feel like a millionaire.
I don't think millionaires
are eating those,
I'm going to be honest with you.
Oh, hell yeah. Oh, yeah.
Yep. That's a good cookie.
Let's talk about the drinks.
First of all, there are
some hot and cold coffees
which are available in both countries.
It does seem like the US
actually has a bigger range
of coffees, particularly when
it comes to the iced versions,
while in the UK we're limited
to a couple of basic ones
like an iced latte. Over
here you can get all sorts.
You can get things like
your iced caramel mocha,
your frappa mochaccino,
Dunkin' thingymajiggy.
You know the ones.
There are some interesting
non-coffee drinks though
that I do want to try and talk about now.
We're going to start with
this one down the end,
which I believe is Hawaiian Punch.
Not common in the UK at all.
Joe: [laughs] Yep.
OK.
If this is the first one,
I think I have a bit
of a storm coming here.
It's pretty good, but, wow, is that sweet.
This one is an American-style lemonade.
As I've said before in the show,
lemonade in the UK is like Sprite.
It's, like, a clear,
carbonated lemony beverage,
whereas this looks like
a good old-fashioned
American lemonade.
It's not bad. It's weird to me
that lemonade isn't carbonated,
but that's pretty good. That's
actually fairly refreshing,
unlike maybe the Hawaiian Punch was.
Also, happy birthday, Grimace,
while we're on the subject.
They did have a special Grimace shake,
but the ice cream machine was broken
at the McDonald's that
we went to, of course,
so I haven't been able
to get the Grimace shake,
which I'm really sad about.
Here's what it's supposed to look like.
They do not have a good
old-fashioned cup of tea
on the menu at an American McDonald's.
What they do have is sweet tea.
I felt like I had to try it as a Brit.
You know, I have to give my
thoughts on everyone's teas.
Aah.
Joe: [laughs] No!
They weren't kidding when
they called it sweet tea.
So, this was supposed to be a
blue-raspberry frozen Fanta,
and this was supposed to be a frozen Coke.
However, now it is just a
melted blue-raspberry Fanta
and a melted Coke,
otherwise known as Coke.
Ooh. That's pretty good.
Yeah, just tastes like Coke.
It does somehow, like, still
has a bit of fizz to it,
and the same with the Fanta, actually.
I do think I would like
these if they were frozen.
I think on a really hot day, for example,
carrying a frozen Coke
around sounds delightful.
So, yeah, would quite like
those on the UK menu, maybe.
Then we have a, what I
believe to be, Hi-C drink,
Hi-C Orange Lavaburst.
Yeah, so this isn't carbonated,
and it's not fruit juice.
It's somewhere in the middle.
I'd put it reasonably close to an Oasis
that we can get in the UK,
which is also a sort of
non-carbonated fruity beverage.
I don't love it.
Last but by no means least,
we have milk on the menu.
I think this is kind of aimed at kids.
I never want to meet a
person who is a grown adult
and goes to McDonald's and
orders milk with their meal.
These are all the exclusive
drinks we got today.
There are some other
ones, and here they are.
All right, the McCafé exclusives.
They didn't label any of
them, so I'll just guess.
That's definitely hot
chocolate, but let's see,
how does it compare to the deluxe?
Mm-mm.
Oh, this is that butter
thing. That's terrible.
We'll get back to that. Let me
find the other hot chocolate.
That's a hot chocolate.
I can't tell the difference.
I don't know which one's
deluxe. Would deluxe be size?
Wait, this one has that
buttery oil floating in it.
And this, I know what this is.
Tea!
I don't get it. I don't
get why this is so popular.
The McCafé food's pretty good. I like it.
You got a good selection
here. The drinks, not so much.
I like banana, I like
banana-flavored stuff,
and we don't nearly have as
much in the United States.
This tastes exactly like a
banana Laffy Taffy. It's great.
What's Oasis?
Yeah, no, thanks.
I mean, it's sweet, but
it reminds me of Gatorade.
Orange juice. I know what
orange juice tastes like.
What is this? Robinsons Fruit Shoot.
Why is it a Fruit Shoot?
What's the shooting part?
Leon: It's for kids, really.
Oh, so it's just, like,
shoot it in my mouth,
like, "aah"? That what it's for?
Leon: I think it's called that
because kids are more likely
to be like, "Yeah, give me a Fruit Shoot."
Than what?
Leon: Than, like, "Give me a Coke."
I would like to know why
this is called Fruit Shoot.
OK, so I think it's called,
I haven't looked it up,
I think it's called Fruit
Shoot because it wants you
to squeeze, like, shoot it
in your mouth, like, "blah!"
And Leon thinks it's because
it sounds better than saying Coke.
Now we're going to talk
about the most important meal
of the day, breakfast.
We'll start with this one,
the steak and egg McMuffin.
That doesn't really look,
taste, or feel like a steak.
Now, next up, America has some
breakfast biscuit options.
So, from what I've seen,
a biscuit looks very much like a scone,
which is obviously a classic British dish.
Now, the fact that they would
be putting breakfast food,
like bacon, eggs, sausages,
into what is effectively
a scone is weird to me
and I think will be weird
to a lot of Brits as well.
So, this is just a
classic sausage biscuit.
It does look pretty like a scone.
It's maybe a bit more,
like, smooth on the outside
than I'm expecting from a scone.
So dry.
Joe: Told you.
Harry: Oh, my God.
Hey, Joe from "Food Wars" here.
I just wanted to say, that's not a scone.
It's a different biscuit.
I don't know what he's talking about.
He'll be chewing on that
for the next four minutes,
but it's different.
He's right. It's different.
It's not a scone. It's somehow worse.
Yeah, apparently I chose badly
with the sausage being my first one,
because that was dry as a desert.
So let's have a quick bite
of a bacon, egg, and cheese,
which is a classic American-slash-New
York breakfast combo.
It's still pretty dry, but the addition
of the other stuff definitely helps.
What are the takeaways there?
Scones and biscuits are
different, not the same.
A scone is a little bit more crumbly,
generally slightly sweeter.
These are not sweet.
Slightly more bready texture.
I'm still not convinced by
the notion of them as, like,
the foundation of a breakfast sandwich,
just mostly because of how dry they are.
But, hey, who am I to
judge American culture?
Now, these I'm excited for.
I've heard very good things
about these from Joe.
These are McDonald's McGriddles.
If I remember correctly
from watching Joe eat these,
they've got pancakes that
they sort of inject with syrup
and then use those as the
buns for a breakfast sandwich,
which sounds pretty excellent.
I'll try the bacon, egg, and
cheese. See how we get on.
Still slightly dry, but way less dry
than the biscuit, and very tasty.
I'm going to go even more syrup,
because what's better
than adding more syrup
to something which is
already full of syrup?
McGriddles, yes. Biscuits, not so sure.
So, this was the bacon,
egg, and cheese McGriddle.
You can also get McGriddles with sausage,
sausage and egg and cheese, or the steak,
which I will not be trying.
The next exclusive breakfast item
is the bacon, egg, and
cheese breakfast bagel.
We used to have bagels on the
menu at the UK McDonald's,
and they were wonderful.
Part of the breakfast menu,
toasted bagels with your choice
of toppings and fillings,
really good.
Pandemic hit, they cut them from the menu,
and they've not returned.
And personally, I'm furious about that.
Yeah. I've missed you so much, bagel.
Next up, we have a sausage burrito.
Breakfast burrito is really
not a thing in the UK.
We're just generally bad at Mexican food.
This is obviously designed to be enjoyed
with the mild salsa.
It's actually pretty good.
And then lastly on the
breakfast menu, we have these,
the Big Breakfasts.
The standard Big Breakfast
is a slab of scrambled egg,
a sausage patty, and a biscuit.
And this is the Big
Breakfast with hotcakes,
which is the egg, biscuit, and sausage
but then also comes with two pancakes.
Both of these come with dips,
including a little thing
of whipped butter and, of
course, the hotcake syrup.
So, I wasn't sure what the difference was
between pancakes and hotcakes.
Joe's just done a quick
Google, and apparently,
hotcakes tend to be a bit
thicker and denser than pancakes.
I mean, to me, that just
tastes like a pancake.
I'm thinking maybe they've
just called them hotcakes
to make them sound more
fancy or different,
but, yeah, not bad.
And, of course, McDonald's
UK, I gotta try the breakfast.
All right, first up,
the mini potato waffles,
hash browns that are shaped like a waffle.
I don't know why this specific shape.
Yeah, dude.
For some reason, it tastes
a lot better in waffle form.
I don't know why that is.
These are really good.
What do we got here? Breakfast sandwich.
This is the bacon roll with brown sauce.
It's like a hamburger bun! Look at this.
There's your brown sauce right there.
Hm. Eh.
It's just OK. Nothing special. It's bland.
I'm starting to think that you in the UK,
you guys don't like, your
stuff isn't as, like,
intense as ours in America is.
Like, this wouldn't fly
in the US because it's not
dripping with cheese and
doesn't have an egg in it
and the buns aren't, like, über-buttery.
It's just too plain. It's too boring.
This is the same thing with just ketchup.
Aw.
Now we're getting more in my speed.
This one has cheese and
bacon in it. Oh, yeah.
Is that sausage?
Yeah, this looks more like something
that you'd get in the US.
Yeah. Cheesy flatbread, oh, God.
Cheesy — oh, come on, guys.
Yeah, see, this is the bacon.
This is more like the bacon we're used to.
Charlie: So, that's streaky bacon.
Streaky bacon? So, this is bacon,
and the other thing was
Canadian bacon in the US.
I don't know why. Or ham,
I'm going to call it.
I mean, this just looks like,
I mean, this looks like whatever.
Yeah, this sucks. And that's why it sucks.
It's like, the flatbread is too strong.
I can barely taste the streaky bacon,
which is what I came here for, so.
Double sausage. OK, so with this,
you guys just went double meat on both.
Oh, man! Yo!
Look how much sausage is
in here. Look at that!
Hell yeah. Now we're talking, UK. See?
Although, nothing in between
the two sausage patties is, like,
it's gotta go cheese, meat, cheese, meat.
You can't just do meat. This doesn't work.
And possibly a sauce. No
sauce is weird for this one.
Your sausage is weird.
I would say ours is spicier. Not heat,
but the flavor of the
sausage is more pronounced
in the US one compared to this.
So, I know in the US, our
sausage is made up of,
and from what I understand,
the UK sausage is made up of.
And that was all done in post.
I have no idea what it says.
Like, here's the thing.
I like the double, but needs more cheese,
needs to be drowning
in some sort of sauce.
But this one I'm assuming
then is double bacon.
No, this is not double bacon.
Wait, one, two pieces
of bacon's double bacon?
This is double for you guys? For real?
Yo, you're getting ripped off, guys.
Excuse me, you've made a mistake.
You come back in like, come
storming in and cut in the line,
be like, "Ah, you made a mistake on mine.
There's only one slice of bacon on this."
So, all right. Let's try
with this double bacon.
I mean, it's ham.
Yeah, that's standard. That's not double.
This is smart that they did the jam.
I don't know in the US they
have the squirtable one.
I mean, do I need to, like,
I mean, I know what a
muffin and jam taste like.
I'm not like ...
Harry: Have you had a
British muffin and jam?
If I eat this,
will I still have had a
British muffin and jam?
I think after this, I
still will have no idea
what a British muffin and jam taste like.
All right, all right, all right.
All right, everyone relax.
Oh, yeah, that is really good.
This tastes way better
than the crap that we have.
Like, way better!
So, I have just been
informed that in England,
these are just called
muffins, not English muffins.
Porridge. I'm from the US.
I don't know what porridge
is. I'm assuming it's oatmeal?
So, from what I can tell,
you can get porridge four different ways.
One with golden syrup,
looks a lot like honey;
one with strawberry jam,
straight from France;
one with sugar, which
they did not include;
and then one plain.
So, first I'm just going
straight porridge, no chaser.
Yeah, that has no flavor to it.
Leon: Have some golden syrup on the side.
Yeah, all right.
So, I've been informed that
golden syrup is good stuff.
I don't know what's the
difference between golden syrup
and I guess whatever other syrups.
You're right, it's like,
it's not quite maple syrup,
but it's pretty close.
Makes it much better, obviously.
Joe: All right. Overall, Harry,
of the American exclusives,
what were some of your likes
and some of your dislikes?
Hm. Some of the things I liked,
you guys have a much bigger
breakfast menu than we do.
I did like the McGriddles.
They did live up to Joe's
pretty high billing.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
I also think that your bacon
is much better than ours.
So I think maybe the double
Quarter Pounder with bacon
was a strong highlight there.
Some dislikes, there's a few.
I don't like the
biscuits. I'm sorry, guys.
I think they are, like,
for a British person,
too similar to a scone.
So we can't really mentally differentiate
between the two, and it's just quite dry.
And also I think, like,
making your burgers deluxe
by just adding loads of mayo, some tomato,
and lettuce just is a bit underwhelming.
Not really a deluxe vibe for me.
Joe: So, if you could
bring one thing to the UK
from the US, exclusive, what would it be?
If I could take one of these exclusives
that I've tried today back to
the UK with me for our menu,
I think I'm going to have to pick
the bacon, egg, and cheese McGriddle.
I think it was really good.
It's a bit of a twist on the
classic McMuffin formula.
Feels a little bit more decadent, maybe,
a little bit more sweet.
And, yeah, just really good fun.
I like the emphasis you guys
place on your breakfast menu.
Joe: And what was the thing
you just hated the most,
you're like, "Ugh, let
that stay in the US"?
Well, the thing that I hated the most
and would want to remove
from all possible menus,
it's tricky. There are a couple.
But I think it might have
to be the sausage biscuit.
It was so dry.
And the notion of a
biscuit-slash-scone breakfast sandwich
to a British person is just too bizarre.
I can't get my head around
it. And, yeah, not the best.
Gotta say, I really disliked your bacon.
Your bacon is weird.
It ruined everything that it was on.
I love bacon, but your bacon
is just, it is bizarre.
The things I liked the most,
I obviously like the curry dipping sauce.
I like the banana milkshake,
separately, obviously.
That triple chocolate
chip cookie was good.
Harry: All right, Joe,
you gotta pick one thing
to take back with you
to the US from our menu
and you gotta pick one thing to remove
from our menu forever.
I'm taking back the curry dipping sauce.
I've wanted to try that since
we shot the first episode.
And then, take off your menu,
I mean, those veggie
dippers were pretty dismal,
but I don't want to leave
vegetarians out in the lurch.
The thing that's, like,
haunting me the most
was the grilled-chicken wrap.
I don't even think it was
grilled. I think it was boiled.
And I feel bad that that's
on your menu, and it's gross.
And I will do the UK a favor:
all grilled chicken off
the menu, McDonald's.
You're welcome.
Joe: A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's KFC.
This is "Food Wars."
We're going to start with
some things you can get
in both the US and the UK
to see if there are some
subtle differences in
taste or anything else.
The first thing for me to try,
the main event, the fried chicken.
So, this is just original recipe chicken.
I've got what looks to be a thigh piece.
Visually, I think it probably
looks slightly more appealing
than British fried chicken
from KFC tends to look.
I always struggle to identify
where the bones are in pieces of KFC.
I don't want to just bite
straight into a bone.
Mm-hmm.
OK, yeah, this is good.
Compared to the UK, I think I definitely
am getting more flavor.
I think a fair amount of that
is coming from the breading.
It's actual seasoning and flavor.
It's a thick, juicy piece of chicken.
I don't want to go back to eating regular
British KFC after this.
Right, this six-piece bucket.
This looks like it has more skin
than what we got in the
restaurant, I will say.
So already this looks like
it has a better batter to it.
That is so bland.
I can taste the flavor.
It's just not as strong,
and I'm assuming that's the chemicals
we put in our food to
make it taste like, wah!
The next thing that we
wanted to compare was
popcorn chicken, which I
think in the UK is a pretty
iconic menu item, although weirdly enough
they've actually cut it from
the menu in the US right now,
the exception being that
they will still add it to famous bowls.
But we'll get to that later.
So I guess for the time being I will try
a US chicken nugget and
see how that compares.
I mean, this just kind of
looks like popcorn chicken.
Definitely a bit more dry on the palate.
Again, I don't see why they've
gotten rid of popcorn chicken
in lieu of these, because
popcorn chicken is
effectively the same thing.
That's like a shot!
[air horn blowing]
Oh, half in.
No. I don't taste anything.
So far I would say that KFC chicken,
both on the bone and popcorn,
in the US, the flavor is more pronounced
and has more of, like,
a savory flavor to it.
This flavor has training wheels.
It'll get there someday!
Firstly, there are some twists
on the classic fried chicken
which we can't usually find.
The first variety we have here
is the spicy fried chicken.
I mean, visually this looks fairly similar
to just the sort of
standard original recipe.
Although I will say the
breading looks pretty good.
You get a lot of these
little flakes of breading,
which really tend to get
crisp and stay crisp.
I don't know if there's
enough to call it spicy,
because I'm not a guy who has
a super-high spice tolerance,
and for me that's, like, warm,
but not much more than that.
But it's very pleasant, and I do think
it's crispier than the original recipe.
Very juicy, flavorful.
I think this is really good.
I think I would be tempted to buy
this over just classic original recipe.
And it's not just spicy chicken
that's available in the US.
You can also get another
type called extra crispy.
As the name suggests, it's
the regular fried chicken,
but made extra crispy.
I think extra crispy
should be the KFC chicken,
and then the original
should be, like, diet.
For some reason, the branch
that we went to today
didn't have it in the form of regular,
original recipe chicken,
but they did have it in the
form of a chicken little.
I'm just going to break off the end bit
that was untouched by the mayo
to see if it is actually crispy or not.
I don't think this is extra crispy.
Even though they told us it was.
Maybe their crispinator was
broken today or something.
KFC US is very good at
cooking chicken on the bone,
less good when it comes to
cooking chicken off the bone,
because this is a little
bit dry, a little bit chewy.
Moving on, the snack wrap.
This one is the flamin' hot.
Oh, wow. This has got some heat to it!
OK, UK!
Yeah, that's, I like
this. This is really good.
Kansas barbecue. OK.
This barbecue sauce is pretty good.
I mean, this is definitely
a sweeter sauce,
which I think is indicative
of Kansas City barbecue.
Anyway, yeah, not bad.
Sweet chili bites.
Too sweet. Not that spicy.
Now we're on to an item
which I've been watching from
across the pond with a mixture
of horror and fascination.
It's the KFC famous bowl.
Instead of me trying to explain it,
I feel like we should
just get Joe in here.
Joe, do you want to come and
explain the famous bowl to me?
A little bit of everything
that's on the menu,
just in bowl form,
for anyone who just pretty
much has given up on life
and doesn't care as long as
they get it in the stomach.
Thanks, Joe.
Joe: You're welcome.
Harry: It's looking more like
an infamous bowl right now.
I'm going to ...
It's not horrible.
There's just a lot going on.
There's a lot of flavors fighting
with each other right
now, vying for supremacy.
The main thing I get I
think is the corn, actually.
I would've assumed that
the mash and the chicken
would've been kind of
the stars of the show.
But if anything, it's
everything else in there
that you can actually taste more.
To me, it feels a little bit
like you're eating baby food for adults.
I was going to say I'm more
excited to try the next bowl,
but I don't know if excited is the word.
Maybe less anxious to try the next bowl.
This is the KFC mac 'n' cheese bowl,
but the kind of color on that
is some cause for concern.
So, I think this actually works
in harmony with the chicken
much better than the famous bowl does.
If I had to get a bowl, I
think I would be leaning more
towards the mac 'n' cheese
bowl than the famous bowl.
Next up is the KFC pot pie.
It's funny to see this on
the menu at a KFC in the US
because I feel like meat pies
are generally associated
with Britain more.
We love a meat pie in the UK.
Steak pie, chicken pie,
Greggs, Pukka Pies, all that good stuff.
So, with a meat pie in the
UK, what you'll often get
is the pastry on the bottom as well.
So it's like a self-contained pie.
Whereas I think with a pot
pie, you just have a layer
of pastry on top and
then filling underneath,
and there's no bottom layer of crust.
But let's find out.
They haven't skimped on the carrot.
I taste a lot of the carrot flavor.
In the UK, for example, with
a meat pie you tend to get
a gravy that will kind of
run out when you cut into it.
But this is staying on the spoon.
It's not running off the spoon.
It's not great, but it's not bad either.
It's like, the sauce needs
a little bit more seasoning,
I think. It's a little bit bland.
Bit more salt and pepper
would not go amiss there.
I think with a few minor adjustments,
they could make this really good,
and I do think Brits would go for this.
This is super weird. Look at that!
There's a hash brown in there.
What does that have to do with tower?
Not much.
Hm.
I like everything that this is made of.
Together, I don't think it works.
If I was to get this, I'd
ask them to separate it
across three containers
and just eat the hash
brown, then the chicken,
finish it off with a slice of cheese.
There you go.
This would be closer to
what our extra crispy is.
So this is supposed to be the spicy one.
It's going to zing me with spice?
Not bad.
It's not that I dislike
anything I've had so far,
it's that it's all 60%
to 70% as far as flavor
and intensity that I'm used
to in the United States.
You can also get yourself a zinger stacker
and a zinger tower burger.
Yo, this is a thick one.
Wow!
I'm not going to bite into
this, but, man, that's a lot.
This would be right at
home on the US menu.
This would be like, "Yes, of course."
It'd be, like, the double
zinger, and everyone's like,
"Yeah, of course it's double."
OK.
Vegan burger.
It kind of looks like chicken.
The mayo pretty much missed it, right?
See how it came?
So I gotta kind of activate the mayo.
Twist your vegan sandwich
before you eat it!
Should I even ask what the mayo's made of?
I mean, when you rip it apart, it's like
one of those big erasers that
you get when you're a kid.
I mean, I wouldn't just
want to eat this in general,
but as far as a fake
meat, it's pretty close.
And I don't know why if you were vegan
you'd be like, "Finally, a
chicken sandwich at KFC."
No, you can eat this, there's
no chicken meat in it.
It's like, yeah, but you're still
killing them by the millions.
So, there is a category in the menu
of twisters, rice boxes, and salads.
They had no rice boxes or salads.
They did, however, have the twisters.
But this is called a twister, not a wrap.
Leon: It's twisted.
What's twisted about it?
Well, it's not twisted.
It looks like they took a chicken
breast and cut it in half.
And this was, like, one long tender.
I mean, it's also smaller.
I bet they wanted to appeal
to a more male demographic.
So, "Don't get a wrap, get a twister!
I'm a big man! I don't want a wrap.
I want a twister! Yeah, it's twisted!
Wraps are for the ladies,
but the dudes have twisters. Ah!"
I don't think that, they think that.
KFC, shame on you.
Let's talk about some exclusive sides
that you can't find in the UK.
Firstly, if the mac 'n' cheese bowl is
too much mac 'n' cheese for you,
you can just get a little cup as a side.
You can also get a side of corn.
You guys just produce so much of it.
You can't get rid of it fast enough.
I'm not trying corn on the cob.
Here in the UK, you guys
have corn on the cob.
Obviously ours is corn off the
cob, but this would be easier
for driving or eating on the go, right?
Have you ever seen someone
walking down the street
just chewing on a cob on a stick?
It's on a stick!
You've never seen that?
Keep your eyes peeled. I would
like to get that trend going.
And, of course, apparently it wouldn't be
a US fast-food menu without biscuits.
This is an American biscuit.
It looks a lot like a British scone,
at least on the outside.
However, generally I think
it's a bit more bready
and maybe slightly drier than a scone.
[thudding]
Texture check.
It's confusing because
with a British scone,
they're generally sweetened with sugar
because they're eaten with
things like jam and cream,
and it's more of an afternoon
tea/dessert type thing,
whereas these ones are
supposed to be eaten
with a savory meal but
actually smell kind of sweet.
I think of the biscuits I've tried
from fast-food menus in the US so far,
this is probably my favorite one,
but it's somewhere between, like,
a British scone and a bread roll.
Baked beans.
Ugh. Eh. Yeah, these
are way more tomatoey.
To-MAH-to-ey, excuse me.
The tomato sauce that
it's in is similar to
whatever Spaghettios come in.
I will never be in the mood for that.
Southern rice.
What the hell?
I don't know what they think Southern is.
I'm surprised at how different it is.
You'd think an international food chain
would want it to be the same everywhere,
but playing to the UK tastes, I assume.
KFC in the US has a bunch of sauce options
that we can't get in the UK,
which means it's time for:
Sauce talk, "Foreign Exchange"!
The theme seems to be that
they have a lot of honey
on the menu when it comes to
their sauces at KFC in the US.
The sauces on offer here are hot sauce,
honey sauce, a honey barbecue sauce,
KFC sauce, and yet more
honey, a honey mustard.
I usually like a honey
mustard, but I do think
you have to get the balance
of honey and mustard right.
Yeah, that's not bad. That's
a pretty well-balanced
honey mustard, I think.
I'm intrigued by KFC sauce.
I quite like it.
I really can't put my finger on exactly
what's in it right now.
Next up we've got the honey barbecue.
Oh, extremely sweet.
Both on the honey side and
even on the barbecue side.
Let's have a look at the honey sauce.
It's fine. It does taste
pretty much just like honey.
And then finally they have a hot sauce.
Yeah, that's pretty comparable
to, like, a Frank's RedHot.
Barbecue!
OK, Kentucky smoked barbecue.
Actually, this is on point.
Sticky sweet chili sauce.
Why is it sticky?
Yeah! Oh, that's good.
All right, garlic buttermilk mayo.
I like all three of
those things separately.
Mm! Yeah, that's pretty good.
Now let's look at some exclusive drinks
served in these delightful
"Diablo"-branded cups.
You guys love a advertisement
tie-in, don't you?
So, I believe this one is Starry,
Joe's beloved Sierra Mist,
unfortunately culled recently
and replaced by Starry.
Let's give it a try.
It's more what I'm used to, I guess,
from a UK version of a
lemonade-style drink.
And, of course, we have
a US-style lemonade.
It's pretty good. Again,
to me it's slightly weird
what Americans consider lemonade,
considering coming from the UK,
lemonade is basically Sprite.
It's a clear, carbonated, lemony beverage.
It's pretty good.
It's probably slightly more
refreshing and hydrating
than a Sprite is in the UK.
There are a couple of
other exclusive drinks
which we can normally get,
but unfortunately our
local branch did not have,
devastatingly, because I really wanted
to try the Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning
and regular American Mountain Dew.
When we ordered the bottles
of drinks, didn't we think
it was just going to be, like,
a personal one? I don't know.
Tango, orange.
Ugh, 7Up free.
Pepsi Max cherry.
Krushems! UK of course has
exclusive Krushem drinks.
I have them in front of me. I
said, "Give me one of each,"
and they did. Milkybar.
Mm!
Aero. Is that normal?
Charlie: It kind of was advertised
as a "healthy" chocolate.
Leon: Because it's got more
air in there. It's healthy.
We're still charging the same,
but you get less in there, so, OK.
Less calories by default
because it's filled with air.
I might be the last
person to point this out,
but, like, they took the candy bar,
and they crushed it, and
that's why it's Krushems. OK.
Oreo one. I mean, come on.
That's really good. I
would definitely get this.
Dessert.
Exclusive desserts. You get a
white chocolate chip cookie.
You can also get a pineapple stick,
but they didn't have any
at the location we went to.
Also, I don't know what
a pineapple stick is.
Leon: It's a terrible dessert.
Joe: Why is that dessert?
I think if I could pick
one item from this menu
to take back with me to the UK
and put on our menu over there,
I think it would probably
be the spicy chicken.
I just like how it was
slightly more crispy
than the regular chicken and
just added a bit more flavor.
The level of heat was really good.
Yeah, I think that
would come back with me.
If I could remove one thing
from the US and all other menus
from KFC, I think it
would be the famous bowl.
I'm sorry, guys. I don't want to start
some kind of revolutionary war again,
but I just feel like it's not very good,
because those ingredients
don't really go together,
texturally, it's a bit of a nightmare,
and honestly there's
just way better things
you can do with the stuff on the menu.
I was really impressed
with the flamin' hot wrap.
I might have dogged on
it a little bit earlier
because it was smaller,
but that spicy sauce
you guys have is actually pretty good.
Honorable mention, the vegan burger.
Obviously, I'm not vegan,
but I guess I was surprised
by how kind of decent it was.
It's not my favorite, but, I mean,
points for it being edible. Way to go.
I will do everyone a favor,
and I will say I'm not
cutting a menu item.
Let's get that potato
off of your sandwiches.
They just don't work together, period.
Joe: A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's Burger Kings.
This is "Food Wars."
So, obviously you can get a Whopper meal
at a UK and a US Burger King.
But we did want to get
them in both countries
and compare the two to
see the differences.
This here of course is
a standard Whopper meal.
I believe it was the regular size.
And this would be a small in the US.
Just a quick visual check,
I mean, the Whopper itself looks identical
to the Whopper that I'm
used to seeing in the UK.
Really, really no changes there.
The toppings seem to be the same.
You get the mayo, the pickles,
the lettuce, the tomato,
onions, and of course
the beef on a sesame bun.
So that's, yeah, exactly what I'm used to.
Let's take a look at a UK Whopper.
Looks exactly the same, so that's good.
Same size. Yeah, it's a big one, right?
Same stuff on the inside.
Oh, and I got a regular one.
I didn't even get it with
cheese, which is rare for me.
That tastes pretty similar
to what I'm used to.
The beef is pretty
similar, if not identical.
You still get that flame-grilled thing
that Burger King is kind of known for.
American mayo so far has
just been very creamy,
but pretty much everything
else is the same.
Overall, very similar to the
Whopper that I'm used to.
Exactly the same, which is
good. But the fries, however,
your fries are a bit different, I think.
Honestly, the fries, this
is a large Whopper meal.
I was kind of expecting
bigger for the US, you know?
There's a good portion of
fries, don't get me wrong.
But I feel like in the US,
if you order a large fries,
I was expecting, like, a lot of fries.
They look pretty similar to
the fries that I'm used to.
They're fairly thick-cut,
thicker-cut than, like, a McDonald's, so.
These are pretty good
fries, I have to say.
I feel like when I go to
a Burger King in the UK,
I'm not really there for the fries.
The fries are just very much
a sort of add-on to the meal.
These are good. These taste way better
than the fries that I'm
used to from Burger King.
I don't know what
they've done differently.
They're quite aggressively salted,
which I personally really like.
But they're just well cooked.
There's a little bit of
crisp on the outside.
Still quite nice and fluffy on the inside.
The US Burger King has —
the fries are weird.
There's some sort of batter to them.
I can't describe it. They
changed it years ago,
and they're a more distinct flavor.
I don't dislike them,
but they're not that great.
These regular fries, I think I prefer
the UK Burger King fries
over the US ones, definitely.
And of course, the fountain Coke.
I hope that the camera can capture
the scale of just how large this drink is.
I have a big head.
Yeah, I mean, it's
fountain Coke. It's fine.
Yeah, this regular drink is so tiny.
I've just been informed that a whopper
can be considered an insult
in the UK. What does it mean?
That's funny.
Have you been called a whopper before?
Someone called you a whopper?
I think generally
speaking, fairly familiar.
Pretty much what I'm used
to in terms of the burger.
I've enjoyed these fries
more than I enjoy the British fries.
And the Coke is too big.
Dial that back a little
bit, guys. Calm down.
Here's everything you
can get at a BK in the US
that you can't find in the UK.
Here are all the UK Burger King menu items
I cannot get in the US.
Let's take a look at
the US beef exclusives.
We'll start with this, the Whopper Jr.
Look at this thing. It's tiny!
I mean, yeah, I think it's
just a scaled-down version
of the Whopper. It's got all
the same toppings on there.
Now we're going from one end of the scale
straight to the other.
We're going from the junior
Whopper to the triple Whopper.
As the name suggests, it is a Whopper,
but instead of the one
patty, you get three.
I mean, I don't necessarily object
to the existence of a triple Whopper.
I will say I've got some
notes on the assembly,
because there's no layering going on.
Obviously a Whopper doesn't have cheese.
This is literally just the toppings
and then just three meat
patties back to back.
So I feel like when you bite into this,
you're just going to get a
big mouthful of just beef.
I mean, I will try it for science.
I'll take a little bite of the triple.
Yeah, that's kind of confirmed my fears.
I'm also covered in mayo.
Next up, we're off to Texas,
because this is a Texas Whopper.
In case you're wondering
what made this Texan,
it seems like they've just added
some jalapeños,
bacon, cheese,
and mustard
to a standard
Whopper.
I don't really know
enough about Texas culture
to know if that makes
something Texan or not.
I would've expected
maybe some barbecue sauce
if you call something Texan,
but they seem to have not
done that. So, we'll see.
I'm a big mustard fan,
so I like the inclusion
of mustard on this.
Yeah, that's not bad. I don't
know if I would order that
just over a standard Whopper,
but I think it's better
than a triple Whopper.
This is the BK double melt,
with a signature cheesy sauce
instead of a slab of cheese.
They just drizzled the, excuse
me, melted liquid cheese.
The melted cheese is kind
of a nice texture to it.
A slice of cheese would
just as easily suffice.
Bacon double cheeseburger XL, Charlie.
Two patties, cheese in the
middle, cheese in between them.
Very smart, guys. See?
It makes a difference.
It's bigger than — in America,
we have the regular bacon
double cheeseburger.
This one is a little bit bigger.
Well, it's extra bigger. So there you go.
Yeah, I like this.
And I would probably get this
if I went to Burger King.
I think this would do
really well in America.
Come on, two big beef patties,
dripping with cheese
and bacon. And it's big.
It's like, its selling
point is that it's big.
Dude, this would clean up in the US.
If this is in the US,
we gotta get US bacon.
Look at this. Come on, guys, look at this.
How, like, not pink this is.
This is like, oh, this bacon's bad.
Then we have two more burger exclusives,
which are the kings.
First up, we have the
Single Quarter Pound King.
This is a single quarter-pound patty
with some onions, pickles,
cheese, mustard, and ketchup.
This looks pretty good
to me. This looks like
a very classic hamburger,
which I'm kind of here for.
I will say, in general,
what I'm really enjoying
about all of these burgers is the pickles.
I feel like America does
pickles way better than we do.
I thought that was going
to be better than it was.
I don't know why. I don't
know what's wrong with it.
There's quite a lot of onion in it.
Just a lot of raw white onion.
And then the next one
I think we might have
had recently on the menu,
or it might still be
on the menu in the UK,
but is a bacon king.
Either way, I thought this
would be a good opportunity
to talk about fast-food bacon.
This is a double burger,
some cheese in the middle and on top,
along with a few rashers of
bacon, some ketchup, and mayo.
Let me just prize a bit of
this bacon off this burger
so we can get a closer look.
So, this is the famous
American fast-food bacon.
So, I feel like the US and
the UK do fast-food bacon,
and I guess bacon in
general, pretty differently.
This in the UK would be
called a streaky bacon rasher,
which is where you get
the kind of thin strips,
as opposed to back bacon,
where you have a medallion
and then some strip coming off it.
Generally speaking, in
the UK, fast-food bacon
tends to be quite a pallid
pink, fairly unappealing color,
and can be quite floppy as well.
They don't tend to cook it
basically for long enough.
I will say this bacon has
a lot more color on it
than I would expect to see
from British fast-food bacon.
That's pretty good. I think
that's probably better than
the bacon that I'm used to
from a British fast-food chain.
So far, all the bacon I've
had, including this one,
it just tends to have a better texture.
There's a bit more chew to it.
It's just been cooked a
little bit longer, I think.
Also, it lends itself to
giving it a much nicer color.
And you definitely get more
of a smoky flavor from it
that you would expect from good bacon,
which I don't think you tend
to get from UK fast-food bacon.
Yeah, the gourmet kings.
Let's go! Ooh! Fancy.
First one, farmhouse,
straight from the farm.
You got your rocket, aka arugula.
You got your ... pickled red onions?
And, like, a smoky cheddar cheese, right?
This is actually,
this is pretty impressive
looking, I gotta say.
Ooh, brioche bun.
Now here we go.
The arugula, or rocket, kind of ruins it.
I like it, but it's such a strong flavor,
it just really tastes like
arugula, rocket, whatever.
So having a bite without
it is a lot better.
So, unfortunately I think
the arugula's a little much.
This one also has arugula on it, so uh-oh.
Let's get a look in there, man.
They got the barbecue
sauce, crispy onions, right?
And the same cheddar, same fun cheddar.
The arugula's kind of still
a little overpowering,
but with the fun stuff, and
this cheese that's on here
is really good, the smoked cheddar.
This one's good. I would
get this. I like this.
So steakhouse over farmhouse.
Then we have a couple of very adorable
tiny burgers down at the end.
This one is the Rodeo burger.
So we're going back to
the South for this one.
To make this Rodeo, they've added
barbecue sauce and some onion rings.
See, the only reason I
can think of onion rings
counting as Rodeo is that
maybe it looks a little bit like a lasso.
Lasso.
No.
And then finally we just
have a double cheeseburger.
You guys got the Memphis barbecue burgers,
single and double. Go side by side.
You know, we, in the US, we got something
called the Rodeo burger. I
don't think you have that here.
Where it's onion rings and barbecue sauce,
and it's surprisingly good.
But it's, like, the smallest
thing. It's, like, that big.
But this is a good idea.
This is that, but adult size.
Yeah!
I gotta get a bite, but I gotta make sure
I get an onion ring in it, so.
This works really well together.
This all works. The creamy mayo,
the mayo and the barbecue sauce
and the onion rings, and the bacon?
Yeah, dude, this is good!
Another thing that would
do so well in the US.
I don't know why we don't have this
in the States, as you say.
I will say, they'd have to rename it.
It'd have to be, like, the Rodeo
burger deluxe or something.
I don't know what about this is Memphis.
I mean, the barbecue
sauce, it's a sweet sauce.
I don't know what makes it
"Memphis-y" specifically.
And I'm still not clear on
why onion rings equals Rodeo.
Then we're on to some chicken,
fish, and side options.
We'll start with these ones,
which are chicken fries.
Now, I'm pretty sure we can get these
or have had these in the UK before.
However, when we were recording this,
it seems as if the only ones available
are the Doritos chili heatwave version,
whereas these are the
old-fashioned classic ones.
These things are great. I love these.
I don't want to know how
they form the chicken
into long strips like this.
If British people are
familiar with Fridge Raiders,
the snacks, kind of like a bigger,
hotter version of those. It's great.
Next up we have a chicken sandwich option,
which is the chicken Jr.
As Joe just pointed out,
they love calling things
"Jr." at Burger King in the US.
Personally, I think they
should be called the prince.
You know? You have the
Burger King as the main one.
The little one should be a prince, surely.
Like a chicken duke,
or archbishop of beef.
It just looks like a very
simple chicken burger.
That's pretty good.
The mayo's quite creamy and quite sweet.
Chicken royale. Looks
just like the regular
original chicken sandwich we got at BK.
Longer, though.
Ah.
Oh, wait, but this one
has cheese and bacon.
Hm. Yeah, this looks kind of upsetting.
Kind of a bummer.
OK, crispy chicken Memphis style.
I do like the Memphis style.
Onion rings and bacon
and chicken with cheese?
That's a new combination right?
Yeah. Yeah to this. Yeah!
I think because it's fried chicken,
it adds even more flavor to it,
with the bacon, cheese, and onion rings.
It's a bit much, but it actually
works pretty well together.
I think we gotta Memphis up
some of our BK in the US.
Or just call it Rodeo-style it up.
Then we have a fish option, the big fish.
It's fairly reminiscent of a
Filet-O-Fish from McDonald's,
in that it's got that kind of shiny bun.
I do like a good fish sandwich.
Yeah, that's really not bad.
The fish is, like, fine.
It doesn't taste of a ton.
An acceptable attempt at a fish sandwich.
Probably not quite as
good as a Filet-O-Fish.
Then we have a side option
we can't find in the UK.
It's mozzarella sticks.
I feel like, yeah, we have now hit a point
where pretty much everywhere
does its own mozzarella stick.
What I will say is it
comes with a little thing
of marinara sauce, which
I think is the only
exclusive sauce at a US Burger King.
So we can do a very,
very short sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
The sauce is pretty strong, actually.
That's a concentrated tomato flavor.
It's almost like eating a tomato puree
rather than a marinara sauce.
Acceptable mozzarella sticks.
I probably wouldn't be
rushing toward those again.
Plant-based Whopper.
I'm pretty sure I did
this in the US, right?
But your guys' plant-based
meat is different than ours.
We have the Impossible meat in the US.
So, our Impossible
Whopper, Impossible meat
has a chemical that is under review.
You guys have a different
plant-based meat than we do.
So let's see what it tastes like.
It's not ... bad.
It's not flame-grilled-flavored enough,
you know what I mean?
Like, the Whopper, the
meat, you just taste
that grill smokiness, charcoaliness,
whatever you want to call it.
And this, it looks like
they cooked it the same way,
but I'm not getting that same
flavor from this meat at all.
So it still tastes like meat,
but it doesn't taste like a Whopper.
It doesn't have that
smoky flavor to it. So.
And I don't think that has
anything to do with the meat.
I think you guys have got
to flame grill it more
or add the same flame-grill
chemicals onto this
as you do the regular meat.
This is noticeably different
than the UK Whopper.
Vegan chicken.
Ew.
This looks exactly like the
original chicken sandwich, so.
There's something weird in here.
There's something weird to that flavor.
I'm just going to take a little —
Oh, this is not a good sign.
This meat is not easy to pull apart.
Ah! Ugh.
Nah, it just tastes weird.
It doesn't taste like chicken.
It tastes like it's
flavored like the chicken.
But the consistency of
it is just different.
I wouldn't say it was bad.
It just tastes like it's not chicken.
These came and went in the US so fast,
I didn't get a chance to try them.
But now I finally do.
Looks like a nugget.
Yeah, it just tastes like
a fake something or other.
Maybe the batter on this seems
thicker than regular nuggets,
so I'm getting almost all batter flavor,
which I guess isn't that big of a deal.
This doesn't taste like chicken.
Again, it's, like, blank.
It doesn't have much flavor to it.
Yeah, I mean, I think
you guys gotta step up
your chemical game, because our
fake meat tastes way better.
And these are chili cheese bites.
Actually, not that bad.
It's mostly — ooh, got a
little bit of heat to them too,
the jalapeños. Yeah, these are good.
On to the fries. Cheesy fries.
Oh, man, this is really phoned in.
This is really phoned
in. No effort on that.
Look at the bacon. It's not
crispy. It's, like, right?
This is the bacon they
have at an omelet station
to put in your omelet
pre-diced or whatever.
But this is like, guys,
it's gotta be crispy or nothing. Come on.
Nothing to it. It really
seems like a waste.
All right, sauce-talk time.
Got the sweet chili
and the smoky barbecue.
There's also a spicy mayo.
Wasn't available at the Burger
King we went to. Oh, well.
It' time for sauce talk,
"Foreign Exchange"!
Sauce talk.
The first one, sweet chili, boys.
Sweet chili is having a moment in the UK.
It's growing on me. I think
sweet chili's really nice.
Smoky barbecue.
Oh, this is a collaboration with
Bull's-Eye steak sauce, or barbecue sauce.
Was a big player in the sauce
game a decade or two ago.
But I feel like I haven't
seen Bull's-Eye in a while.
Mm, this is pretty good.
Here are all the US exclusive
breakfast items from Burger King.
We'll start on this
end, where we will find
breakfast biscuit sandwiches.
Now, if you saw the McDonald's episode,
you'll know that I didn't really like
their version of a breakfast biscuit.
This is the ham, egg, and cheese.
You can also get a bacon, egg, and cheese
or a sausage, egg, and cheese.
Now, I'm still not convinced
by the notion of a breakfast biscuit.
To the UK mind, this kind
of looks like a scone.
I will say this one kind
of feels a bit more buttery
and a bit more moist than
the McDonald's one did.
So maybe it won't be as bad.
It's hard to tell if this is
actually like a scone or not.
This has more of a sort of bready texture
than a scone does, for
the British audience.
I feel like a scone tends
to be a bit more crumbly
and doughy, whereas
this one is more bready.
As for the flavor,
there is a pretty similar
flavor, I would say,
in that the sort of main
taste you get is butter.
I don't know. It's pretty good.
Next up we've got the Croissan'wiches.
Now, for the uninitiated, like myself,
this is a breakfast sandwich,
but instead of a bun or a biscuit,
they use a cut-in-half croissant.
These come in the form of
bacon, egg, and cheese;
a sausage, egg, and cheese;
a ham, egg, and cheese;
or you can get a fully loaded option,
which comes with all of the above.
You get the bacon, you get the ham,
and you get the sausage patty.
Coming from a country that is
in pretty close proximity to France,
I feel like I do have to speak up
on behalf of my French friends out there.
Because, yeah, they just
look a bit sad, really.
I will say I kind of have more faith
in this idea than a biscuit.
Because at least a
croissant will be hopefully
flaky and buttery pastry
and not quite as dry as a biscuit will be.
I will say, there are
some places in the UK
that will do a ham and cheese croissant.
But it's usually a full-size
kind of crescent-shaped croissant,
which they would just cut in half
and then add the cheese, a
bit of ham, and then toast it.
These, I don't know.
It's the fact that they've
got the small circular ones.
So they've clearly been
purpose-built to be buns.
I'm not really sure about that.
I'll try the big boy.
I'll try the fully loaded Croissan'wich.
It's actually not the
worst delivery system,
because it is quite thin,
it is quite buttery,
and you do get a little bit
of the flakiness that you'd expect.
As much as I kind of
disagree with the concept
of a Croissan'wich, if you made me choose
between one of these
or a breakfast biscuit,
I do think I'm choosing these,
because it's closer to just a sandwich.
For all the Croissan'wiches,
you can also get a double-meat version.
So you can get double meat of the bacon,
of the sausage, and of the ham.
I don't think you can get a
double fully loaded version,
because that would just be kind of insane.
Then we have two
breakfast-burrito options.
We have the Egg-Normous Burrito
and the breakfast burrito Jr.
If this is Jr., then is this his dad?
My favorite thing to do is
just invent fast-food lore.
I'm not 100% sure what's
in either of these,
so let's find out.
Oh, wow. Some sausage.
[laughs] Oh, God. Oh, no.
Oh, God. Oh, oh, there's,
like, rice in it.
I mean, I've really made a mess of this.
I'm sorry, guys.
So, I'm seeing what looks
like half a sausage patty,
some egg, and what I think is rice.
Give it a quick try.
That's a reasonably
palatable breakfast burrito.
And then the big boy, the Egg-Normous.
All right, what do we got in here?
Bacon, quite a lot of rice.
I'm not seeing any sausage in this one.
I'm pretty sure it's just
egg, bacon, and rice.
Let's give it a quick try.
It's OK. So, to me, this
does taste a little bit
claggy and hard to chew its way through.
However, I'm told it's supposed
to come with a salsa verde,
which I think they've
forgotten to give me.
So, maybe if I had a salsa with it,
that would ease the
digestion a little bit.
Also, this is called
the Egg-Normous Burrito,
but it's really not very,
like, this is not enormous, guys.
Come on. If you're going
to call something enormous,
we're in America, I
want properly enormous.
And then finally we have
some French toast sticks.
What is Burger King US's beef with France?
They're really just going for France here.
So, I don't think I've ever
had French toast before.
It's not really a thing in the UK.
So, in the UK, we have
eggy bread, or egg bread,
which is whisked-up eggs.
But it's a savory thing, because we're not
putting vanilla and
cinnamon and stuff in it.
Harry: I will have
basically just egg in bread
that I will fry in a pan
and then maybe eat with some ketchup.
I'm being told I have to
try this with the syrup,
so let's give that a go.
British person tries French
toast for the first time.
I mean, it is pretty good.
Joe: Yeah, of course. It's French toast.
This is even more egregious than pancakes.
Because this is like a churro
that you then dip in syrup.
Somehow that's for breakfast.
Not convinced if that is
a breakfast food or not,
but it's very tasty.
One last thing to note is
that at a US Burger King,
you can actually buy
several burger options
before 10:30 a.m.
While they're still
serving the breakfast menu,
they will also make you a
Whopper and I think a bacon king.
I'm not really sure who wants
a Whopper at, like, 9 a.m.
There's obviously exclusive
Burger King breakfast menu items,
but since the pandemic,
a lot of Burger Kings
are still working on a reduced menu.
They're almost nowhere
to be found. We looked.
Apparently you're only
finding them in, like,
service-station locations.
So, we looked around.
Couldn't find a place
that served them. Sorry.
Here are some drinks that I
can't usually find in the UK.
We'll start with this one,
which is Hi-C fruit punch.
That's such a deeply unnatural color.
Joe: American drinks, baby!
High-fructose corn syrup, let's go.
My British palate has not adjusted
to American soft drinks yet,
because this thing is aggressively sweet.
This one's Dr Pepper. I can't remember
if this is on the UK
Burger King menu or not.
But, I mean, I like Dr Pepper in the UK.
Let's see if it's the same in the US.
OK, yeah, no, that's
actually pretty comparable.
Burger King in the US also
has some milkshake options.
This one is the Oreo cookie shake.
This comes highly endorsed by Joe.
Did you say this was your
favorite fast-food shake?
Joe: I would say, yeah,
one of my favorites, yeah.
One of his favorites.
Joe: One of the best ones, yeah.
High praise. Let's give it a try.
I mean, yeah, that's delicious.
That is so thick. The straw
almost isn't up to the task.
Yeah, that really does taste like Oreos,
like the filling of the Oreo.
And then if that's not
enough chocolate for you,
they also have a chocolate
Oreo cookie milkshake.
I mean, yeah, it's
basically the same as that
but I think just with chocolate ice cream
instead of vanilla ice cream as the base.
Yeah, I don't think you need
to mess with the formula.
Stick with the classic.
Stick with vanilla.
OK, for drinks, Burger Kings in the UK
also have tea and espresso,
and the one we went to
didn't have hot drinks.
And they also have various Capri Suns,
which they did have and we did
order and they forgot them.
Then we have some Burger King desserts
that we can't find in the UK.
We have two options. Firstly,
chocolate chip cookies.
Seems like these come in an order of two,
which have cemented themselves together.
They don't look brilliant. They're quite
hard on the outside.
[cookie banging on table]
Don't know if cookies are
supposed to make that noise.
Those are quite overbaked.
Then we have a slice of
Hershey's sundae pie.
I'm kind of intrigued by this.
It's come pretty highly recommended to me.
I like the packaging. This is quite fun.
Don't bite your nails, kids.
Makes it very hard to open
Hershey's sundae pies.
I really don't know what
to expect from this,
but I guess I'm just
going to get a scoop out
and see what happens.
Is it pastry on the bottom?
I can't really figure out what's going on.
There's, I think, like, a sort of cakey,
biscuit base type thing.
Yeah, that is very rich
but also very tasty.
If there was one menu
item that I could keep
and take back with me to the UK,
I don't actually know if it would be
a specific menu item, or
maybe more like an ingredient.
I think I would take the
bacon that you guys have
at a US Burger King and
take that back to the UK.
Because I feel like here it actually
adds something to a burger, in
terms of texture and flavor,
whereas in the UK it's just kind of there.
Like, you don't really notice it.
And if there's one menu
item that I would delete
from all possible Burger King menus,
I think it would be that triple Whopper.
I think it just really was
everything that is wrong
with American fast food in general.
It's just kind of excess
for the sake of excess.
You don't need that much meat.
You need some kind of
lubrication in there.
It's just dry, chewy,
horrible. Get rid of it.
Harry: So, Joe, you've tried
all of our Burger King menu items.
Which one are you taking
back with you to the US?
I think I like the Memphis
barbecue burgers the best,
because it was like a Rodeo burger
but it's bigger and it
had more stuff on it.
So I think I could really get into that.
Harry: Then you can knock one
thing off the UK menu forever.
What's going?
What was it? Oh, that fake chicken.
The chicken royale specifically.
It was the consistency of
the chicken, how it tasted.
It just tasted off. It
tasted really weird.
Like, my body was like, "Do
not swallow. Spit out now."
So I feel like as a nugget
version, it would work.
But as the chicken royale,
didn't work. It's gotta go.
A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's Domino's.
This is Food Wars.
We're going to start by
comparing a menu item
you can find in both the US and the UK
to see if there are subtle differences.
This is a US large cheese pizza.
This is their largest size.
Feels like it's a little
bit bigger than our medium.
In terms of visual impressions,
it looks pretty similar to a cheese pizza
that I'd find in the UK.
This is the large, not the extra-large,
and honestly it looks
pretty much like the size
that I would expect from
a large pizza in the UK.
Otherwise, it looks pretty
similar in terms of the crust.
Obviously a lot of cheese on that.
You get these little, like, spots
where the cheese kind
of caramelizes on top.
Yeah, pretty much like
what I'm used to in the UK.
It seems pretty close, actually.
I can definitely tell
this is mozzarella cheese
and not whatever weird pizza
cheese we have in the US.
So yeah, this is like,
it's like a cleaner taste.
I like this. This is good.
Give it a try.
I haven't had a Domino's in ages.
It's also looking like
there's a pretty high
cheese-to-sauce ratio on that.
I feel like if you look at
the kind of cross-section,
it's a lot of cheese
and not a ton of sauce.
That's really not that bad.
I have had some New York
slices while I've been here,
and it's kind of
comparable to one of those.
I feel like I might offend some
New Yorkers by saying that.
There's a lot of, like, talks
happening around the room right now.
What I mean by that is I
think like in terms of the way
that the cheese and the
sauce blends together,
there's, like, less of a distinction
between the cheese and the sauce.
It kind of just all forms one mass,
and in that regard I
feel like it's similar
to a New York slice.
There are some differences though.
The crust on this is,
like, way less crispy
than I have come to associate
with the New York slice.
There's also maybe not
quite as much flavor
as some of the slices that I've tried.
Here's all the UK Domino's menu items
I can't get in the US.
And here are all the Domino's
menu items from the US
which you can't find in the UK.
You guys have exclusive dough options.
I don't know about this one, guys.
The Double Decadence.
You got like a double-layer
crust with like a garlicky
cheese in the middle there.
Here in the UK, a garlic-and-herb
stuffed-crust pizza.
This one also looks terrible.
Then a crispy crust.
This has to be half-priced,
or you're getting ripped off.
What is this crust?
Producer: It's Italian-style.
What's Italian-style?
Yeah, it's like, not as
thin, but it's still thinner.
So man, you guys really get specific
with the thickness of your crust.
They want to dial that in, huh?
Yeah, this, I'd be like,
in America, this would be the thin crust.
This would be like, yeah I
got the the thin one, right?
And then this would be
like, people just rioting.
Domino's in the US has crust options,
which we don't have in the UK.
We'll start with this one,
which is the pan crust.
I mean, it looks pretty good.
It is obviously much thicker
than the standard hand-tossed slice was.
You do get that kind of like
pan-crust bottom there as well.
I like that you get more sauce
and more distinct areas of sauce on this
than the standard slice.
I think often for me,
the sauce is kind of the star of the show,
especially when it's a fast-food pizza
and the cheese generally doesn't have
that much flavor to it.
I will say I was expecting it
to be crispier on the bottom.
When you see the kind of, like,
the cook marks on the bottom,
I was expecting that to
be a nice, solid crust,
but it is kind of squidgy.
Not too bad.
Let me try a little bit of crust.
It's slightly crispier on the edge.
Next up, we've got the Brooklyn crust.
Now, I've already made
comparisons to New York slices,
which have drawn some
criticism from the room.
But this is supposed to
mimic a New York slice.
As I now know from a New York slice,
generally you're talking
low-moisture mozzarella,
the sauce, and that kind
of mixture of like crispy,
but a little bit floppy on the crust,
which, kind of this is
doing, to be honest.
So it sort of looks like a New York slice.
But does it taste like one?
No.
No it doesn't.
I'm sorry to the great state of New York
for what Domino's has done to your pizzas.
And then finally,
Domino's in the US does
a gluten-free base.
I don't know what they've
done to this gluten-free base.
They've cut it so weirdly.
Can you see the cross-sections on this?
I think maybe they were
trying to do it into squares,
but have just completely
messed up the angle.
So now you get these like weird
kind of diamond-shaped slice
in the middle, some like tiny
triangle ones on the sides.
I don't know.
Joe: Oh, man. Right?
Oh man.
No.
That's bad.
What have they done there?
Yeah, that's a miss.
I feel like if I were gluten-free,
I think I might just skip Domino's.
All right, let's go through these pizzas.
Vegi Volcano, veggies and
jalapenos making it volcano-ey.
Let's go, spice it up.
You know, this is good.
Off to a good start.
The next veggie, the Veg-a-Roma.
This one has, like, a
lot of seasoning on it.
No.
Here we got the, this just
says spicy, our hot and spicy.
Not that spicy. I mean, I'm
seeing the jalapenos in here.
That other one, the
volcano one was spicier.
Tandoori hot.
OK, I am excited for this. I'm for real.
There's no tandoori
chicken pizza in the US.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
I like that.
Compared to other tandoori chicken,
this probably is, like,
not even remotely good.
But on the pizza, yeah,
that's a cool, that's like a,
that's a nice flavor profile
combination they got there.
Yeah, good on them for that one.
Good job.
So here are all the
Domino's premade pizzas
I can get in the US which
you can't find in the UK.
On like a sort of visual level,
these look a lot busier
than I would expect
a pizza in the UK to look.
Like, these things are topped.
So we'll start with this one,
which is the Philly cheesesteak pizza.
Philly cheesesteak, an
iconic American food.
I've never really had
a proper American Philly
cheesesteak before.
This is my introduction to them,
which I'm sure the people of Philly
will be thrilled to hear.
It's very creamy, and I think the texture
of the American cheese is a
bit like claggy in the mouth.
I don't love the peppers.
I feel like the peppers are
kind of overpowering it a lot.
They've been really
generous with the peppers
and not super generous with the steak.
I feel like if you flip the
ratio of those toppings,
this would be OK.
Next up, we have the Wisconsin six-cheese.
OK, so this is a very cheesy pizza.
I'm told Wisconsin is known for its dairy
and, I suppose, its cheese production.
They've actually been quite
generous with the sauce
under the cheese, which I like,
because you need it to, like,
cut through all of that dairy.
OK, the Vegi Supreme.
Oh, no.
Corn on pizza, no!
Oh, God, I can really taste the corn.
Meatilicious.
Guys, come on.
Oh, no!
I'm realizing something,
I do not have a taste for UK sausage.
Whatever we've been
getting for these shoots.
I think because your
guys' is pork and beef,
like the way you're spicing it,
there's something about it.
I get it why you guys would
like it. You grew up eating it.
We'll get Harry a sausage
when he comes to the US,
and you'll see what I mean.
Maybe it's a different type of sausage
and we just name it something different,
but this sausage you guys have is weird.
Oh, yeah.
Texas.
I see the barbecue.
Besides that, why else is this Texas?
I see chicken, I see a few
sparse slices of bacon or ham.
Yeah, all this stuff is in Texas.
This does not represent the
state of Texas in any way.
Next up, we have the ExtravaganZZa.
This one I think is
probably the most chaotic
in terms of toppings.
What have we even got on here?
I'm seeing ham,
pepperoni, sausage, mushrooms, peppers,
onions, and black olives?
And I feel like I still might
have missed some things.
I feel like I'm being
overloaded right now.
You think you've kind of like identified
what the flavor of it is,
and then you bite down on
something else, and then suddenly
you're tasting something
completely different.
Next up is the Memphis barbecue pizza.
Now, this one has the barbecue sauce base.
I believe it does have provolone
as well as mozzarella on it,
which might explain some
of the extra cheesiness.
And then you have some onions
and the grilled chicken.
I know it is a sweet
barbecue sauce technically,
and they are not kidding
when they say that,
because this is a very, very sweet,
very, very sweet barbecue sauce.
And I think that does kind of overpower
anything else that's going on.
Mighty Meaty.
OK, oh, yeah, this guy again.
This has to be half-price or
you're getting ripped off.
This thing.
The cheeseburger pizza.
The cheeseburger US
pizza I did really like.
Burger sauce is on here?
Yeah, I like this.
It's good.
I'm eating them on the pickles.
Ladies and gentlemen, the Absolute Banger.
What is absolutely banging about this?
OK, one, two.
Three.
Just bringing it all to the front, guys.
One bite.
I don't know if it's really banger.
Next up we have the deluxe pizza.
This looks like a slightly
less chaotic version
of the ExtravaganZZa.
There's still like a
lot of toppings on here,
but not quite so many.
It's not like piled high
like the ExtravaganZZa was.
See if it tastes any less chaotic
than its slightly more packed-out cousin.
What I'm realizing is I don't
really like peppers on pizza.
I feel like it's quite a strong flavor,
and when you get a fast-food
pizza specifically,
where most of the toppings
and the cheese and the sauce
don't really offer that
much in terms of taste,
I feel like you have to be quite careful
with your flavor balance.
And peppers are kind of
throwing that off for me.
Next up we have the Cali
chicken bacon ranch.
So this one has chicken,
bacon, diced tomatoes,
I believe our old friend
provolone is back again,
and, of course, there
is ranch on this pizza.
You can see the ranch.
So it's basically the ranch
in lieu of tomato sauce
on the bottom.
I still think I just prefer
tomato sauce on a pizza.
I don't think I will be
swapping out my pizza sauce
for ranch anytime soon at home.
Good lord, guys, no!
I'm going to try a meatball.
Could someone intelligent
in the comments explain
the difference between
US sausage and meatballs
and UK sausage and meatballs?
It's just, it's notably different.
The Meateor.
Too much. Too much.
Vegi Sizzler?
It's spicy. It's sizzling.
I know this is weird to say this,
but is it unfair or
cheating to market something
as being really sizzling and spicy
if all you're doing is dumping
jalapenos on it, right?
I don't think they did anything to, like,
it's not like a spicy sauce.
They didn't add like
any other spices to it
from what I can tell.
They just loaded it with jalapenos,
which is like, well, right,
but a little more effort than that, guys.
New Yorker, what?
I feel like I've seen this before.
Producer: You did.
No, in the past five minutes.
Next up is the spinach feta pizza.
I think I'll stick to my spanokopita
instead of my spinach and feta pizza.
This is the Buffalo chicken pizza.
We have chicken, onions, and
quite a lot of Buffalo sauce.
That's barely even a pizza.
I don't know if you can call that a pizza.
Oh, no, it's the breakfast
brickie! Or the Brekkie?
Oh, look what it did to the box.
What is on it?
OK, I'm seeing mushrooms,
the sausage, ham,
tomatoes, and HP sauce.
I think people would get this
as a novelty and then realize
that the jokes on them when it shows up.
Here we go with the vegan Margherita.
They were generous with the herbs,
whatever, the extra herbs.
They're generous with that,
which is code for this has no taste.
Tuna Supreme.
Oh, God, it looks like cat food.
Tuna on pizza is horrifying.
I see no Venn diagram of
enjoyment of those two flavors.
Two completely separate circles.
I feel like every alley cat's going to try
and like break in here through the window.
Oh, you people are insane.
This whole island, maniacs.
Oh, give me, I've got
to eat anything else.
The taste in my mouth.
What's the next one?
I don't even care what it is.
Chicken Feast.
Oh, with the corn!
That's good, anything else.
Yeah, yeah.
If you want to sell more
Chicken Feast pizzas,
just give away free tuna pizzas.
And then people are like, I
got this taste in my mouth.
It's like, it'll cost
you, got it right here.
Yeah, you're going to move
a lot of Chicken Feasts.
Next up, we have the Pacific veggie pizza.
Not sure what makes this Pacific.
Are these veggies
exclusive to the Pacific?
Because as far as I can tell,
there's mushroom, onion,
olive, tomato, spinach?
It's OK.
Having eaten several pizzas in a row
that contain meat in some form or other,
I was quite looking
forward to a veggie one,
hoping it would be a bit
lighter, but it kind of isn't.
And then finally the last specialty pizza
on the Domino's US menu is the MeatZZa.
Having just gone from a veggie-only pizza,
now I'm going to a meat-only pizza.
This one has bacon, ham,
pepperoni, and sausage.
There's something about American meat.
But I think it's just
generally a lot saltier
than what we're used to in the UK.
As I was chewing that,
I could just feel my
mouth like drying out.
I think generally my
takeaway from this section
is you guys need to
just calm down slightly,
because this is too much.
All right, we got here reduced-fat cheese,
which I've been told is on
the UK or the UK-only pizza.
Oh, you.
OK, I don't know what to show you.
I mean, it looks like cheese.
And then vegan cheese.
But it comes with its own
garlic-and-herb dip, vegan.
Let's see what the vegan's got going on.
It tastes sour.
Sauce options you only get in
the UK, starting over here,
just a straight barbecue sauce.
We have honey barbecue,
they have regular barbecue.
And then over here, this
monstrosity has sun-dried tomatoes
and garlic sauce.
They have four exclusive
meat toppings here in the UK.
Hotdog slice is unreal.
Chorizo sausage, sounds nice.
Pork meatballs.
Tandoori chicken, yeah,
that sounds real good.
They also have two meatless meat options,
vegan soya strips and vegan
soya-and-wheat pepperoni.
I think we saw that earlier.
They have seven nonmeat topping options.
Sweet corn, Domino's herbs,
burger sauce, gherkins,
Heinz ketchup, HP sauce,
and garlic spread.
Here it is, the UK-only.
It looks like an alien
community opened a pizza place,
and they were like, here's
that pizza you like.
Like, this is all things humans like,
and all together like this.
Like, the completely
fundamental misunderstanding
of how food works.
That was really bad.
Now, beyond the premade specialty pizzas,
they have some individual
toppings and customization options
in the US which we can't find in the UK.
So Joe has kindly taken a bunch
of the exclusive US toppings
and added them to one
pizza to create a US only.
I don't even know what he's put on here.
The crust looks weird.
I think he's gone thin
crust, banana peppers,
spinach is back on there.
This looks like a meat of some kind,
but I can't tell you which one.
Is that like beef?
The steak from the Philly cheesesteak.
The base sauce has been swapped
out for ranch of course.
A little extra of that and light cheese.
I mean, this thing looks
like a bit of a disaster.
Look how thin that is.
What have you done, man?
Oh, that's bad.
Domino's in the UK also has its own sides
that I haven't had ever,
so why not try them now?
Starting over here.
Potato wedges.
Oh, they have fries, whatever.
Yep, not bad.
Chicken strippers.
Stripping it up.
Just OK.
I mean, the pizza's usually amazing,
so I don't know why you
get chicken strips or fries
at a pizza place.
Oh, the nachos.
No!
Oh, no!
UK, what have you done?
If you want to be a millionaire,
open a decent Mexican
restaurant in London.
You're not going to try very hard.
Just above horrible, two or three steps.
The line will be out the door.
Oh, my God, my soul hurts.
This is so terrible.
Then we're onto some
exclusive US side options
we can't find in the UK.
Firstly, we have tater tots.
Now, if I'm correct,
these are basically balls
of like mashed potato,
which are then fried.
They can then be topped
with a range of things.
The ones we've got here are
Philly cheesesteak tots.
Not bad.
There could be like slightly
more flavor going on.
Then we have two stuffed
cheesy bread options.
As the name suggests, these
are big pieces of bread
topped with lots of cheese
and a filling of your choice.
Here we have a
spinach-and-feta cheesy bread,
and then I believe this one is
bacon jalapeno cheesy bread.
Then we have two twist options.
Here we have some garlic bread twists
and Parmesan bread twists.
Now, you don't eat the twist on their own,
because they come with dips.
So this is a cheesy marinara dip.
It's basically just a bowl
of their marinara sauce
with lots of melted cheese on top.
I kind of see the appeal of
dipping these in marinara sauce.
I don't know if it needs the cheese.
That's such overkill.
I would enjoy that way more
if it was just marinara sauce.
In addition to the cheesy
marinara sauce option,
there's also a five-cheese dip.
That's just pure oil.
Vegan nuggets?
Ooh, I don't like this.
No.
Twisted dough balls.
I bet that was better when it was hot.
Again, why are you getting
this instead of pizza?
Because it's the elements of pizza.
These are the Chicken Kickers.
Prepare for that kick.
And I don't think it's coming.
To be honest, this slaw
looks a little rough,
but you can get a real
big tub of coleslaw.
We're still talking about sides,
but now we're onto chicken.
Domino's in the US has some wing options,
which we can't find in the UK.
We'll start with these ones here,
which are garlic Parmesan wings.
They have not skimped on
the garlic parm sauce,
although I will say these are tiny wings.
What chicken has this come off?
This is the world's smallest chicken.
Maybe one of the worst
wings I've ever had.
The sauce is like a weird, gloopy texture,
which I really do not appreciate.
It doesn't even taste nice.
And the other wing option we got today
was sweet mango habanero.
I'll give these a quick try.
The bar is pretty low after
those garlic parm wings,
I have to say.
It's definitely better than the other one.
The sauce actually tastes kind of nice.
A little bit of tweaking your method
I think would go a long way, Domino's,
so please fix this, because
these are not very good.
Domino's in the US also
has boneless wings.
I'm still not exactly sure
what counts as a boneless wing
versus a nugget, but they're
calling these boneless wings.
We've got two options today,
which are the crispy
bacon and buffalo chicken.
I'll have a quick bite
of the crispy bacon.
These have been disappointing.
I thought Americans did
wings better than this,
I'm going to be honest.
There are two other boneless wings,
which are a sweet barbecue
bacon and a spicy jalapeno,
but we didn't get those today.
Domino's in the US also
offers a range of sandwiches
and pastas.
I don't why, because
they all look real bad.
I'll work my way down this way,
starting with the Italian
sandwich, a chicken parm,
and once again, a Philly cheesesteak.
Although I feel like if you
tried to sell this in Philly,
they would run you out of town.
There are some other
sandwiches we didn't get today,
including a Buffalo
chicken, a chicken habanero,
a Mediterranean veggie,
and a chicken bacon ranch.
Then we're onto the pasta options.
The ones I have in front of
me today are a chicken Alfredo
and a pasta primavera.
I'm going to be honest,
after trying all the pizzas,
I am not going to try these
for the sake of my health.
I've heard from Joe that
they're all terrible.
I think the pastas at Domino's
are an absolute abomination.
And looking at them, I believe him.
All right.
♪ It's time for sauce
talk foreign exchange ♪
Sauce talk.
Thank you.
Garlic-and-herb dip.
This isn't ranch, but it's pretty close.
Oh, you have a vegan one.
I can taste the difference, but
this one's pretty good, too.
Honey mustard.
I'm a big honey mustard guy.
Wow, that's actually really good.
Like your sauces are good.
Tangy salsa.
OK, I think this is where
we're about to fall off a cliff here.
There's no way you got salsa right.
You know what it is?
It's like here's tomato
sauce, here's salsa.
You're like, you stopped like here.
Oh, duh, Frank's.
USA, baby, all the way from Jersey.
Yep, that's Frank's.
I don't know why I did that.
There are four sauce options in the US
which we don't have in the UK,
and these are a marinara
sauce, a blue cheese sauce,
ranch dressing, and a
sweet mango habanero.
I will very quickly give these all a try.
It's fine.
The marinara sauce is very sweet.
Blue cheese dressing.
I like a little bit of
blue cheese on wings.
It can be very overpowering.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's not even that it's
like too much blue cheese.
It's just like there's some
kind of odd flavor in there.
It does taste like slightly soured.
Of course, we have the ranch.
They put this on some of
their pizzas directly.
And for the real ranch lovers,
you can then also dip
your crust in it as well.
I can't open this because my
hands are covered in grease.
It's quite tangy.
And last but not least,
the sweet mango habanero.
I quite like this on the wings.
I think this is like by far the best
and, like, most well-balanced
of any of these sauces.
It looks like for desserts
you guys got cookies.
OK.
And what's this last one?
Oh, God, what the hell is this?
What do I even do with it?
Do I cut it?
Do I just bite right into it?
Listen to me, from what I can tell,
it's just pizza dough with
melted chocolate on it.
No effort on this.
Yeah, it's weird.
Then the US has some dessert options
which we can't find in the UK.
Over here we have chocolate lava cake.
OK, no there is, yeah,
there is some lava in there.
But it's still very gooey on the inside.
Not bad.
Next up we have some
cinnamon bread twists.
So I think it's basically
just the same dough
that they use for the garlic
or Parmesan bread twists,
but instead of topping
them with savory things,
they top them with cinnamon
and then give you some
sweet icing for dipping.
This is really good.
We don't have a lot of like cinnamon roll,
Cinnabon-type of stuff in the UK,
which I think is a travesty,
because I think it's really tasty.
And honestly, yeah, these are pretty good.
And then last, but by no means least,
we have the marbled cookie brownie.
I feel like Domino's are like
surprisingly good at desserts.
It's really not bad.
I think overall, I have to
say I'm kind of disappointed
by the US Domino's menu.
I was expecting some good
flavors, some good textures,
and various bits and bobs,
but I really didn't get much of that.
Honestly, my main takeaway
is that I didn't like most of the menu.
This might be controversial
considering how much I hate vegetables,
but of all like the pizza pizzas,
or like predetermined ones,
I was actually very impressed
with the volcano veggie,
er, Vegi Volcano.
That's like really good.
That was earlier.
I was a little more
optimistic to be honest,
but I was surprised by
how much I liked it.
So yeah, that was a good one.
This sounds kind of ridiculous to say,
but I think if I had to take
one menu item from the US
and bring it back with me to the UK,
I'd probably take the
cinnamon bread twists.
Well, if I had to pick one,
probably the one that
almost made me throw up,
that'd be the tuna.
It was so bad.
Horrifying.
Like I'm glad I know.
But that was, I mean, it
almost made me throw up.
Of the things on the US menu,
I think the one that I would
delete permanently if I could,
would actually be the ExtravaganZZa.
I kind of said it at the time,
but I think it's just
far too many toppings.
I think Joe agrees with me on this one,
so I hope he doesn't push back too hard.
But I think the more toppings you add,
the kind of worse you
end up making a pizza.
There was not a square centimeter
of cheese on that pizza.
It was just toppings, toppings, toppings.
Flavors were all over the place.
It didn't know what pizza
it was trying to be.
It was just a disaster, far too much.
Dial it back, guys.
Calm down.